E
tamam
o zaman biraz şöyle ilk etapta
özellikleri de kalma beyaza koş derken
beyaza karşılarken nikasil biraz bunu
konuşmak istiyorum böyle birşey
canlandırın kafamda tüm gün boyunca da
hem de bir yolculuk anda hep bunu
düşündüm Acaba bugün konuşmam arasında
çok ne anlatabilirim diye geçmişten
kalmasın hikayeler hepimizi gündemdedir
yıllar önce yaşadıklarımız Hala bizi
böyle yönlendirir hala geçmişten böyle
projeksiyon tutar belki burada bir
şeyler vardı şimdi böyle yapmalısın
Şimdi artık bunu vakti geldi gibi ben
geçmişinde yaşadığım hala İkisininde
olduğum ilk gri alanlardan nasıl
kaçtığımı Anlatmaya çalışacağım bunu
mesajları çok alakası var seçtiğimiz
meslekler kabiliyetimizi keşfetme
mücadele duygumuz hedefler çok çok
bağlantı olduğu için biraz sonra kendi
geçmişime gidebilmesi dönemlerine çok
sıkı takip eden arkadaşlar mutlaka da
anca bunu dinlemiş olsalar da bir kez
anlatmaktan bu olanlar da birçok Fanatik
bir futbol takımı merakım var
üniversitedeyim Aslında bir çok kişi
gibi üniversite bir gideyim biliyorsunuz
Artık her şey Tamamdır dediğimiz
dönemler bizim şak biraz ağabey gel
mutlu eder misin nasibi git gerisi kolay
Gerisi gelir gibi indik sonrası Sıla
tabi farkın olmadı başka şeylerle
karşılaştık Ama birçok şey beni çok
etkilemedi ama sadece bir tane çocuğun
etkisi Ben de çok büyüktü bir tane
tartış çocuğun etkisi o çocukla
karşılaşmam şöyle oldu o akşam da
Beşiktaş ve Fenerbahçe'nin maçı var ki
olarak çok komik beşiktaşlıydım tabi
artık futbol çok bir alakam yok maalesef
çok uzun zamandır o güne bağlıyorum
şimdi o günlerde hala deplasmana giden
Beşiktaş'ta alakalı birçok şey Çok
yakına maddi ve manevi takip eden birisi
Hani belki aranızda mutlaka vardır böyle
oradan Büyük sayı para biriktirip belki
yumurta gitmedi forma alma gibi bir çok
şeyi canlandıran böyle masumane olarak
düşündüm ama sonrasında mu o kadını
kendi açından fark ettiğim bir süreci
paylaşacağım o akşam de çok hızlı bir
şeydeki değerli yorum Kayseri bilenler
vardır orada yaşayanlar vardır Bu ismini
vermeyi Alışveriş Merkezi unutan bir alt
geçit var o Hadi tamam yanından geçerken
rahat artık çocuk klasik o soruyu sorduk
herkes gibi bana sordu Sonra dedi ki
artık mısın yok dedim hızlı bir şekilde
ilerledim oradan çocuklu sağ tarafında
öyle düşün hızlıca ilerledim ama şimdi
şöyle bir şey var hani bazen yok de
işiniz vardır amacı da kim Ahmet'i
görünce de böyle hani bir attınız orada
kalır Ya şimdi bir yere gideceğim bir
işim var geri dönüşü de aynı yerden
geçip eve döneceğim Eda arkadaşlar
klasik tam üniversite evi cipsler
hazırlanmış çekirdekler hazırlanmış
çaylar hazır sık olayı cehenneme hepsi
böyle hazırlanmış abi Bilginiz Hani o
şey vardı ya böyle Şampiyonlar Ligi'nde
başlangıcı vardır böyle başlangıçta
sanki herkesin şekil Biz de öyleyiz eğer
biz hazır olmadan maç başlamaz gibi
düşünüyoruz herhalde bir şekilde işimi
hallettim çok hızlı bir şeydi aynı yerde
bu iş yapmak zorunda Çünkü oradan geri
otobüse bineceğim basıp gideceğim sonra
yaklaştım aynı yerden geçeceğim dedi Bu
saat çocuklar çok da göz göze geldim
yani ne bileyim içimizi ve duygusal
tarafta var ya hani ya bir kere daha
hayır demek Ne bileyim hani olmaz falan
diye çaktırmadan bu tarafımız gidiyorum
böyle biraz daha sağ tarafa mağazalar
falan var dükkanlar var bu sarı sol
tarafında kalıyor
çaktırmadan bir bakayım çocuğu biraz
geçtim ama biraz geçeceğiz arkamda
kalıyor şu biraz daha arkada
kaldıracağım ama ben gidemedim ona bir
durdum yanına bir adam bir kadın var
onlar bir şeyler söylüyor Çocukları
ağlayarak cevaplar veriyor bir oldu İki
oldu baba ucuz adamla kadın gün
yapacağız Sonra şu bağlamaya devam
ediyor Allah Adın gidemedim yani bir
merak dedim kalmam lazım galiba dıyemem
bütün çocuğuna şu adamla kalıyorlar
döneminde gitti gitti bana çocuğa biraz
vakit var diye düşünüyorum hala biraz
konuştuk böyle abim dedim Ne oldu bana
bir zaman o kadar tatlı ağlıyor kendi
bana sözler vardı Böyle ağlayışı bile
tatlıdır ne kadar öyle bir çocuk ne
anlatıyor bir şeyler gözler böyle gitmiş
hafta böyle güzel çekip zaten böyle göz
a kayboluyor falan ben Aklımın o anda
belki en az yüzde 60170 halen baştan onu
itiraf etmem yüzde 30'luk bir şey
yapacağım gideceğim kafamda duvar
biraz konuşmaya çalıştım işte Ne oldu
falan anlattı ama anlatıyor anlatıyor
ben ne kadar inanıyorum bilmiyorum aklım
hala yüzü çok bir kısmı var sana
gideceğim anlattığım şunu anladım ise bu
zor şartlar altında bir şeyler yaptığını
anlatıyor tartın yeni almış Adam S kadın
bal Geçmiş olan bir şeyler olmuş Oldu mu
Tamam dedim abi ya boş ver ya Canını
sıkma falan dedim Sen ne kadar borcum de
ben tatlı bunlar verirse taşıdığı biraz
yani okşayın hakkında en son ödediğim
gidip gideyim istiyorum Böyle bir destek
olmak anlamına gibi birşey bir şeyler
oldu biraz konuştuktan sonra dedim ki
artık bana müsaade tahmin borcunuz 25
kuruş 6.25 bu çıkarttım Öyle ellerimize
de para çıkaracağım para yok Elif Diğer
arkadaşa batıyorum para yok şimdi
yadırgamayın son öğrencilik ama inşallah
isterdim yaşıyorsunuz dur yani
üniversite yaşayacaksınız Can
üniversiteli olduktan sonra da eğer
üniversite Tayfa varsa da onlar da Belki
şu anda bile hocam aynı şeyi ben de seni
yanları vardır Biri şöyle bir huyu vardı
ya hani iki uyku vardı bende birincisi
öyleydi Toplu para geçtiğinde böyle bir
kısmını ölecek böyle daha kaliteli
olanları bırak gıcır derler ya onları ön
yüzden bir köşede saklardım Emre
kattayım Dursun Yani biraz kendini
unutturmak yani şey vardır böyle altı
aydır giymeyen moddan para çıkar Yani
evde bir Hani bir mutluysan böyle balgam
onun için değil mi Baran evde sorunsalı
parası tabii ki ben yani Kim bu
dediğiniz zaman vardır Yani aynı onun
gibi cüzdan böyle köşesini atacağım
benim için de oradan çık dışarı çıkarsa
Tamam Çünkü otobüse yüklemiştim o
zamanlar Işık Erciş numarasını iste pas
oluyordu biz onu oraya gidiyorsun buraya
falan Oraya gitmiş bana dedim inşallah
oradan çıkar yani ucuzdan içine Elif 16
20 TL para büyük arama benim buradan
aldım şimdi Dedi Kalkın üstünü ver bu
Aklımın diyorum yarısı yarısından
fazlası maçlar Dedim nereye veremiyorum
mecbur vereceksin Hani ben bu Para üstü
almam lazım senden öyle bir şey yok abi
aldın mı verirsin falan ama çocuk
veremem demiş Ben vermem olmadım sonra
ben bir durdum Orada mısın ya hani
kaşığı kazandı kaçtan beri burada spor
Maya başına zihnin daha o tarafa doğru
yönelmeye başladı abi Savaşçısı dokuz
Ondan beri buradayım şu saate kadar
sanki biraz da derinleşmeye başladım ya
da nasıl çıkmaz ya da tüm cebindeki
bozuk parayı bana verir misin çocuk
biraz da fıstığım ne yapmalı ben
birazcık gerginleşti mi bilmiyorum
inanmadım Yani biraz böyle ya oğlum
kardeşim sen onun saattir buradasın
kazanıyorsunuz falan gibi hakikaten
biraz ödeme kağıdı sahip yani
düşünüyorum hala çocuk çıkardı cepheli
tüm Bozuk paraları teker teker böyle al
buyurdu 20'den üstü kalsın ama tüm
Bozukları istiyorum 19 açık çalışıyorum
bozuk para beş dakika istiyorum teker
teker aldım ama orada bir soruyu sordu
madem bu para çıkmayacaksın Ben 10
saatini buraya karısına Ben etme sen ne
yapıyorsun orada bu kadarsa ve işte
orada anlattıkları bana tüm hayatını
sorgulatacak biliyor musunuz bana şu
sorulabilir acaba benim gerçekten
hayatta bu kadar mücadele ettiğim bir
hedef var mı böyle mücadelen var mı
kabiliyetinin alakalı keşfi Boş verin
şöyle kabul ettim olmayan bir alanda
bile acaba mücadelen var mı Çünkü bana
sorsanız ya da şu anda üniversitedeki
birçok gence sorsanız Bir Hayal bir
hedef üzere oraya gittiğini söylüyor ki
ben de onlardan bir tanesini makat orada
Şunu fark ettim ki ben orada hayalim
içinde bulunuyorum Yoksa bu hayal
dediğimiz şey sadece bir yaşam olarak
bir tasarladığım şeyimize sabrettim şey
mi Yani şöyle arkadaşlarım olacak ev
arkadaşlarım şöyle olacaksın şöyle
şeyler yaşayacağım Sadece bunlar mı o
beni bekleyen bir hayat mücadelesi var
aslı çocukla konuştuktan sonra Şunu fark
ettim ki benim böyle bir hayalim yaşam
amacı mücadelem yokmuş o gün karşıma
8-10 saat çalıştığını ve bu çocuğun tüm
gün boyunca kazandığı o miktarını Yılmaz
merak ettim dedim Acaba ne kadar merak
ediyor ki ondan aldın mı bozuklar hala
buradadır arkamda dır bir kırmızı
kutunun içinde hala saklıyorum Onları
Çünkü hala ben de etkisi olduğu için
söylüyorum bunu
955 kutu falan para çıkmıştı içinde ben
ceplerini doldurdu bunları tekrar eve
gidince Saydım Ben ilk defa o gün
fanatik oldum Hani
bir futbol takımı maçını izlemeden o
günü kapattığımı Hatta o duvardaki
posterlerini teker teker Söktü mü hala
çok yazıyor ve olduğun anlarda alamadım
Bir forma vardı inanılmaz biliyorsun ben
bu formayı almam lazım o dönemde çok
pahalı de fiyatını söylemedi ama bir
cidden çok pahalı geliyordu o zaman şunu
fark ettim Bizler Aslında Hepimiz böyle
gri alanlara sahibiz diye düşünüyorum
hepimizindir yalanları var bakın
hedefimiz var hayalimiz var yok değil
mücadelede ediyoruz etmiyor da değiliz
fakat bunu şuna benzetiyorum ben bu sarı
gömleği Çok fazla benimsediğim anda ya
bu 35 derecede işte kırk derecede bile
hala bu gömlekle yaşamaya devam ettiği
sürece başka şeyler geliştiriyorum yani
çok afedersin çok fazla terlediğim için
daha fazla Paşa taşımak zorunda
kalıyorum Daha fazla elini yüzünü
yıkamak zorunda kalıyorum ama şu
diyemiyorum ya neden Bu gömleği
çıkamıyorum Ben çıkarsa ne Bu gömleği
yani Normalden daha fazla terletiyor
işte bitti Bunu elini bağlantı kocaman
da bu gri alan Belki de bu gömleği
çıkarmam lazım Az önce bahsettiğim
noktada siliyoruz bir futbol takımı
örneği üzerinden gidiyorum o futbol
takımına olan bağlılığını Belki de oraya
verdiğim enerji oraya ayırdığımız bütçe
yaptığım işte görüşmeler diyaloglar
hayalini kurduğu şeyler beni ağlatan
güldürenlerden vs vs toparlayın hepsini
burada bir gri alanlar ilk beyaza
kaçışım Aslında duvardan teker teker
onları sökmek de başladı şimdi burada
hemen bir mesaj çıkalım yani hocam Şu an
tüm dinleyenler gidip futbol takımı
bırakmak Ya tabii ki bu değil O hasta bu
değil kim nerede çok fazla gereğinden
fazla zaman kaybediyorsa enerji
kaybediyor saat taka biletini
keşfedeceği bir fırsatlardan fırsatı
kaçırıyorsa o işte o arkadaşımızın gri
alanıdır kişi diye düşünür şu o gri
alandan beyaza kaçınması hikayesi böyle
başlıyor Ben yıllardır öğrencilerle
görüşüyorum YKS öğrencilere görüyorum ki
ben nasıl yıllar öncesinde bu tenis
konuşmalarını izleyen Bilseydim bir
Hayallerinden bir tanesi duyduğunda
itiraf ediyordu günü birini belki de
böyle bir kanalda Madem insanlara
faydalı olacak şeyler konuşulursa Belki
birgün Bizde orada bir konuşma
paylaşırız ve Ordu insanlar üç beş kişi
bile olsa dinlerler Ben bir farkındalık
oluşturdu Çok iddialı söylemiyor orada
konuşma Şunu fark ediyorum Evet bu
insanlar gri alanlarını genelde terk
eden insanlar Peki öğrenciler yaptım o
kadar görüşmek i11s atarsın görüşmeyi
devrilmiş durumdayız şu anda Ben şunu
fark ettim Evet Herkesin hayatı var
doğru mi Elif var doğru bir sıkıntı
nerede Biliyor musunuz
kabiliyeti üzere bir hedef konulmuyor
çok ne söyleyebilirim bunu şu anda
mevcut eğitim sistemi zaten bir açıklama
bir tane suresi değil mi kabiliyet
tarafının Çeşme yönelik bir şey
yapılmıyor Peki soru Hadi sistem bunu
yapmıyor Peki biz yapmayacak mıyız yani
bu Hadi çok basit düzeyde bir örnek
veriyorum elime alıp bir gitar çalmakla
uğraştığım da ben bunu yapamadığımı
belki bir saatin anlayabilirim hep böyle
kabiliyetim olmadı Farkeder Ama niye
kabul etmeyince sadece akla müzik sanal
spor gibi şeyler geliyor yetenek deyince
kabrin hep bunlar gibi Hayır Aslında
bugün bir arkadaşımızın Ben ülkemi nasıl
öğretmenin olabilirim değişme bir
kabiliyeti orada Çünkü anlatmaya aşık
bir başka arkadaşımızın gece gündüz
bilgisayarla yaptığı aslında bir zaman
kaybı değil Belki de onun gri alanı gibi
duruyor ama bu işi gelecekte maddi yasa
bir mesleğe çevirebilir demesin nokta
şurası Bu bir ne olur Ama ne olur o gri
alanlar Her neyse o kısmı terketmek ilk
aşama mız olmalı yani o kadar sıcak
Salonu gömleği var mı çıkaracağım o
gömlek bir çıksın çıktı şimdi daha rahat
konuşabilir mi Şti O zaman ne çıkıyor
karşıma kabili keşfedildi ikinci kısma
ne geliyor O zaman ben hedeflerimi buna
göre koyarım Çünkü kahvede keşfettim
Artık ülkeni bardaklarını Ben
yapabildiğim düşünüyorlar bardaklar
akıllı benim hayalim kimse düşünmemişti
önce ama çok zor diyorlar ben şunu
söylerim sınav sürecinde de artık
buluşmaya suyunu söylemem lazım olay
olacağını bize kim söyledi bunu
söyleyenler kimler çok merak ediyorum o
yüzden ister Bunu bir tavsiye olarak
Örün isterseniz bir karşınızdaki kişi
Bunu hayat dönem olarak yaşamış biri
olarak görün açsana paylaşalım benim
okul Yalanlarım uyku ysa sosyal medya
ise bu futbol takımımıza arkadaş ortamı
zakone tane 20 tane şey sayabilirim size
çekingenliğimi Zeko Ya oğlum sen ne
olursa olsun bunların hepsi benim
gramında ve ben bunları teker teker
beyaza boyamak zorunda ya da kaçmak
zorunda kadar bunu yaptıktan sonra bir
hedef Buna göre konulacak arkasından tek
bir şey kalıyor mücadelede Daha bugün
bir yerde okudum çok hoşuma gitti Hani
bizim kuşakta sorumluluklar vardır da
bir çadır hep sorumluluklar verildi ama
biz böyle çok anne hakkımızı arayalım
şunu da şöyle sesimi çıkalım ablacık
bilmezdik Hani Çünkü o yoğunluk bizi
Belki bunu yaşattığını da diyor bir şey
yoktu şimdi kuşakta biraz daha
farklılıklar bize göre çok daha iyi
hallerde var Bazen de böyle Acaba böyle
olması Deniz hallerde var okşadığı daha
fazla ufak arama kısmı hakkını sorgulama
olayları sorgulaması çok çok güzel
ilerliyor ama bazen sorumluluk almaktan
biraz kaçıyoruz gibi Aslında en güzeline
bu dengeyi kurmak değil mi Bir anda
benim haklarım var ve sonu haklarım var
Bunları aramalıyım onlar akıllı sistem
böyle tıkıyor Ellerimi tıkıyor
arkadaşımı bunu hepsini arayayım ben ama
ve sorumluluklarını yerine getirdik yani
sadece önümdeki bazı verilere bakarak
yüz kişiden sadece beş kişi bunu yaptı
97 kişi Evet İstiklal önemlidir doğru
hedeflerken hakkından kritiktir fakat
ben şu anda o gri alanımı terketmeden bu
sesleri okursak o gözlük takmadan
bunlara baktığımda maalesef devamı
gelmiyor ben yıllar boyu Şunu fark ettim
kendi çapımda bir Hani bir şeylerin
peşinden ilerliyorum Bu arada bir hayal
hedefim var koştuğumda bugün
geldiğimizde 5-6 saat yoldan geldim
arkasına hala çalışma devam ediyorum
Yarın belki bir benzeri haftayı başka
bir şekil bu hiçbir zaman bitmeyecekti
koşturmaca daha Geçenlerde okudum
yorumları şöyle bakıyorum Hani
Instagram'dan YouTube'dan birçok yönden
yorumlar geliyor hocam siz yorulmuyor
musunuz Yani böyle yeni Tayfa Evet
dönemi başlıyor sınav süreci bir daha
işte başa dönüp oldu ama siz söyle
epeyce bir dinlen sen de dinlen
diyorsunuz ama şu unutuyorlar acaba
yaptığım işte beni dinlendiriyor
olabilir Burası çok enteresan değil yok
ya sadece sevdiğiniz işi yapın mutlusu
da yeterli değil sevdiğiniz işi yaparken
yıllar sonra siz söylüyorum ki ben adam
geçmişte böyle konuşmaları dinlerken şey
yapana kadar mani aile kurma konusu
bölüm bir de karşıma çıktığında olacak
bu da çok merak ettim acaba iş kısmıyla
diyecek tam bir denge hala sen hepsinden
yakardı sadece içtiğimi seçime eş seçimi
Geleceğe dair Aslı bir yaşam standardı
şunu vurgulamak Tan inanılması giderip
uygulama çok çok isterim Konfor alınıp
değil arkadaşlar benim gözleme birşey
oldu Eğer bir kişi Konfor alanından
çıkmak istenirse İstersen bu da gri
alalım ister kontrol oluyor buradan
çıkmak istemiyorsa ya Diğer taraftan
genelde yüzleşmek istemediği şeyler
olacaktır yada bu taraf gerçekten orada
o kişiyi bir süre sonra kaybettirecek
olabilir ama çok rahat böyle konforlu
koltuk düşünme bazen böyle bir video
çekimlerini falan gittiğimizde bana bir
koltuk hocam Buyurun da anlaşılmıştır
oto81 30 bu Atam böyle şeyler böyle bir
beş dakika Kimse konuşmasın 12 dur yazar
uyumadı Uyumadı durumumuz olabilir bu
koltuk bana zarar verir çok net O ne
söyleyeyim o kostüm kalkmam gerekiyor Bu
hafta 15 dakikalık burada idare
edebilirsin Ama beş ayınızda 5 yılınızda
idare edilebilir bir şey değil gelecek
Artık benden bir şeyler istiyor dijital
dünyada iyi Bağlar kurmak istiyor
ülkenin yönetmen olacaksan Ben dijital
dünyada bağ istiyor benden ülkenin
yazmanız olacaksam zaten Dışarı yönde
içinde olmamı istiyor ben ülkedeki en
iyi bardak tasarımcısı olacaksam
ülkedeki en iyi endüstri mühendisi
olacaksa mütercim-tercüman olacaksan
Neyse artık Bunların adı ama dijital
defa kurmak istiyor benden hocam nasıl
dediğimiz o telaş anı var ya aslında biz
de otele Şanlı yıl önce çalıştık YouTube
girdiğimizde inanın bu kameralar
Şuradaki prodüksiyonlar Bunların
hiçbirine elinizden vardı Ne ucunu zaman
ne maddi olarak madde Olsa bile zaten
Bunların ne kadar güzel olma ihtimali
var mı bile bilmiyor ne demek ki için
bir yerden başlamak bir yerden giriş
yapmak gıda mezarı Kaçış yapmak ayrı
resmen oradaki ilk heyecanı ise o
paraşütten atlamak gibi birşey galiba
ise onu yaşadığınızda ilerleyen yıllarda
Şunu fark ediyorsunuz İyi ki buna
girmişim Yıllar önceki YouTube'da
çocuklarıma bakıyorum gülüyorum Hatta
bir çoğunu siliyorum görüntü Ama bu
nedir Hani hiç olmamış ama hoşuma da
gidiyor bu çünkü Ya diyorum hikayeler
böyle olmalıydı ilk seminerlerine
hatırlıyorum dizlerim Titreye titreye
daha böyle köy okullarındaki böyle küçük
salonlarda yaptığımız konferansları
atıyorum o dizlerimi titremesinden
dolayı o sesini titremesine yansımasını
hatırlıyorum Çok şey Ama şimdiki duruma
bakıyorum kendi çıktım hep söylüyorum
Buradaki amaç şu değil ben bunları
yaptım sizde yapıp falan asla bulayım
Herkesin kendi kabiliyetine göre
gideceğim yol vardır Hani bir söz var ya
söz bana ait değil mi Evet hepimiz birer
Fatih olamayız İstanbul'u fethetmek için
ama happy bu gecede bir İstanbul vardır
ve ona inandım hep bu motor yaşıyor hep
kafamda bu var İstanbul varsa o zaman
benim İstanbul'un bu ise acaba Seninki
nerede İnan bilmiyor inan hiç bilmiyorum
O yüzden bunu araştırmak tamamen
Herhalde senin elinde mücadelesini
yapmak işler dünyada bağ kurmak Ali
belki Özel sektör dediğiniz alanda daha
fazla artık zaman geçirmek sadece
benimle atanma yerleri düşündüğümüzde
modellerimiz kırılıyor Sınav Sistemleri
düşündüğünü artık modeller yılı
üniversite tayfadan özellikle ama boşuna
Özel sektör tarafından neden sürekli
düşünüyoruz iş kurma değil sadece
girişimcilik Evet çok güzel iş kurma
şeyleri olabilir Bunlar çok güzel
şeylerdir Ama herkes değişik kendi
başına kullanılabilir bir ekiple
kuracaktı Belki belki yeni bir futbol
takımının defa sonuncu çok iyi bilmeye
bilir ama o defans oyuncusu da bizim
için çok çok kıymetli bir futbol takımı
için ya ben hepsini toparladığımız da
ortaya çıkan sonuç toparlayayım arkasına
noktal ayıp
saç ekimi keşf edeceğim Gece gündüz bunu
aramak zorunda Kitaplar okuyacağım
videoları izleyeceğim danışacağım Beni
tanıyanlara tanımayanlara ne varsa
hepsini akıllı bir şeyler yapacağım
ikincisi burada hedefler koyacağım neyin
işareti varsa benden Şuradaki mıknatıs
nereye çekiyorsa beni onunla dair şeyler
yapacağım üçüncüsü mücadele edeceğim
Gece gündüz sürekli mücadele edeceğim
Ama önce demiştik o mücadele içinde gri
alanlar kaç tane ise ne kadarsa ne kadar
vaktim olursa hepsinden yavaş yavaş ya
da bir anda keserek iki ihtimal var
burada karar Siz de ben yana da mizacım
geri Biraz da böyle keserken bir anda
bırakarak böyle Çetin yollara geçiş
kısmı yaşatıp Belki farklı
arkadaşlarımız biraz daha bunu yavaş
yavaş yapmaktadır bunların hepsini
dijital dünyanın getirdiği birleştirip
ilerleyen yıllarda inşallah o güzel
hayallerinize hedeflerinize ulaşırsınız
diye umut ediyorum benim anlatacaklarım
bu kadar Hepinize çok çok teşekkür bu
ediyorum inşallah faydalı ve verimli
olabilmiştir Sağ ol
[Müzik]